elections in the u.s. are conducted
mostly at the county level there are
over 4,000 counties in the US there are
over 8,000 separate election
jurisdictions in the US and the thought
that a small County somewhere maybe in
an important swing state could have
enough cybersecurity in place to
withstand an attack from state level
attackers is just not realistic even
though we can't defend an election from
being tampered with we can institute
good auditing and one method of good
auditing is this and then verify ability
that allows you as a voter to see
whether your vote has been changed
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if you've ever wondered why in the age
of the internet we still don't hold our
elections online you need to spend more
time with dr. Josh Bonello senior
cryptographer Microsoft Research in
Redmond Josh knows a lot about elections
and even more about homomorphic
encryption the mathematical foundation
behinds the nth and verifiable election
systems that can dramatically improve
election integrity today and perhaps
move us toward wide scale online voting
in the future today dr. ben lo gives us
a brief but fascinating history of
elections explains how the trade-offs
among privacy security and verifiability
make the relatively easy math of
elections such a hard problem for the
Internet and tells the story of how the
University of Michigan fight song forced
the cancellation of an Internet voting
pilot that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Josh Bonello welcome to the podcast
thank you so much your bio begins by
saying that you're a senior
cryptographer at Microsoft Research when
does the senior cryptographer do for a
living get you up in the morning it
varies quite a bit I tend to have a foot
in a few different places I do research
on elections and particularly but
cryptographic protocols more generally
multi-party protocols I do policy work
of various sorts and I spend a lot of my
time doing internal consulting with
Microsoft product groups so what do you
do when you consult with a product rep
do you give them insights into why
they're not as safe as they think they
are well there are a few aspects to this
this benefit to having one part of me on
the research side and one part of me in
the practitioner side because I know
what is being developed I know what's
coming down the pike so I can talk to
product groups about how they should do
things cryptography is very subtle it
seems easy there are some books out
there that are very popular that people
read and think ok I understand this all
and when I go into somebody's office and
I see this on the shelf I know I have a
hard time ahead of me what cryptography
for dummies are there are books with
titles like applied cryptography or
practical cryptography that often
oversimplify things and just the order
in which you do certain steps can make a
critical difference so if I can go to a
product team and they show me what
they're doing and I can say no if you do
a before B you're gonna have a problem
you're gonna regret it you be before a
so do they seek you out the product
groups as help us out here Josh or do
you go around and say hey you guys need
this it's almost always seeking out but
there are a lot of different ways in
which I can work with product groups for
about the past
I think 14 years we've had something
called a crypto board with Microsoft and
the crypto board is responsible for
multiple tasks one of them is setting
corporate policy for how cryptography is
used another is working with party
groups to try to consult and help them
let's talk about this concept of
security we're doing so much on the
Internet these days and arguably we're
gonna do more and more and yet the
internet was not designed with security
in mind so what are folks like you doing
about that yeah it's certainly true that
the internet was not designed for
security the internet was designed by a
few people who knew each other very well
and they were trying to set things up so
that they could communicate with each
other and there was no sense and the
initial designs of the Internet of
having to secure it against malicious
forces more recently we have had to
build security on top of the Internet if
we had designed it initially with
security at the base it would have been
a lot easier cryptography is an
important tool in trying to secure it in
a variety of ways trying to keep data
private trying to make sure that the
people you're talking to or the people
who you think you're talking to trying
to maintain integrity of data which is
distinct from privacy of data and do
basically I should have access to the
data that I'm entitled to have access to
and I should not have access to the data
that I'm not entitled to right in
practice although cryptography is an
important tool there and it's very
widely used now most breaks of the
internet are not about the cryptography
most breaks or maybe the use of the
cryptography or the implementation of
the cryptography or things that even go
around the cryptography we've
essentially got a very good front door
but the windows and the back door and
other parts of the house that we're
trying to protect are more vulnerable
all right we're gonna come back to that
what freaks me out at night kind of
thing I was gonna say what keeps you and
I'm that freaks me out at night
all right Josh let's talk about securing
the vote okay first could you give us a
little election history I mean I don't
know that people think about how we're
voting now and how it used to be and how
it's changed but I think that would be a
good level set for launching into what
you're doing with election security now
sure
well voting certainly goes back for
millennia and attempts at voting
secretly go back for millennia public
votes are difficult to tamper with in
the sense of tampering with the votes
themselves but of course when votes are
public then votes are coercive and
people can sell their votes or have
their arms twisted in devoting
particular ways the history is not a
pretty one people have been stealing
elections for centuries as long as
they've been voting yes for me it's
interesting to note that most US
presidents were elected without the
benefit of the secret ballot
the secret ballot in large elections
actually was a technological innovation
when it came about in the mid 19th
century so the way that people voted for
president or many offices was typically
you would go to a public space and you
would announce in some public way what
your vote was and that makes it easy to
tell who's voting and that the only
authorized people are voting and that
the votes are being counted properly but
it enables coercion in vote selling the
way that we vote in a poll site
in-person voting was a technological
advance in the 1850s it's typically
called the Australian ballot that
process wherein people are voting in
private within a public space so that
the fact that they are voting privately
is publicly monitored and enforced so
this was an innovation at the time and
it took a while to move around the world
in the u.s. the number of US presidents
is different from the
of the US president because Grover
Cleveland was president number
twenty-two and number twenty-four and
that actually came about because of the
lack of a secret ballot so in 1884
Grover Cleveland was elected without a
secret ballot in 1888 his competitor
Benjamin Harrison defeated him again
without secret ballot in an election
that was utterly rife with vote selling
with coercion and it was so bad at that
time that the US moved very quickly to
secret ballots and in the election of
1892 there was a rematch between Grover
Cleveland and Benjamin Harrison and with
the benefit of the secret ballot Grover
Cleveland won again and became the 24th
president
[Music]
okay so we've got the secret ballot now
since the mid 19th century laws the
stuff has happened technologically and
the size of the country and so where are
we now
give us a lay of the land of what the
unique problems are and what you're
doing with technology to work on these
big problems well if we look at
elections broadly they're much harder
than most other problems
the thing about banking or e-commerce or
other fields is that if something goes
wrong I know about it I can have an
opportunity to correct it if my vote is
changed I don't know it there's no way
for me to discover that my vote has been
altered much less corrected that's of
course within the context of the secret
ballot of course if we gave up on the
secret ballot then it would be very easy
we could have a public vote in which
people cast their votes in person by
mail over the Internet even by carrier
pigeon they just make their intentions
known to the voting office and the
voting office publishes a list on a web
page somewhere digitally signed for
integrity purposes so that everybody can
look at the list and see yep my vote is
there it's correct I can see all the
other people who are voting I can check
that they are legitimate voters at least
according to the registration lists of
course the accuracy of registration
lists is another question but that's a
little bit out of scope here and that's
a public process
great yes but I can check that everybody
else who's listed there is supposedly a
legitimate voter and that they have had
the opportunity to check the lists as
well because the list is public and I
can add up the votes on the list myself
but that's not going to happen yes
so it turns out it's possible to achieve
all of these things with a secret ballot
and this is where cryptography comes in
with just a little bit of cryptographic
sauce in just the right places
it's not that hard to achieve the same
things and the basic trick is we can
still have a public list but the public
list is not of my vote directly but it's
of my encrypted vote and everybody
else's encrypted votes so you can still
check that you're on the list you can
still check who else has voted but now
you need means for checking that the
encrypted votes really do correspond to
the tally
that's all math and graphically we can
do that we can compute on encrypted data
in such a way that we can process the
data in encrypted form turned it into an
encrypted tally and then provably
decrypt that tally so that anybody can
check and confirm the whole process and
say yep this all looks good we also need
to provide tools that allow voters to be
certain that the encrypted votes next to
their names which are opaque really
correspond to their selections sure and
that seems hard but it turns out there
are some pretty good ways of doing that
that are quite effective and we can make
that happen as well and I should try to
be clear I'm describing one process but
there's this notion that's called
end-to-end verifiability that enables
this kind of election verification to
take place talk a little bit about
end-to-end verification it's a
definition but there's many ways to get
to it exactly could you break that down
sure the definition of enta and
verifiability is the properties that I
just described
voters should be able to check that
their own votes have been properly
recorded and voters should be able to
check that all of the recorded votes
have been properly tallied you might
think that's missing a little bit that
well but I can't check that your vote
has been properly recorded but in some
sense that's not really possible and any
means without my knowing what your vote
is right so this is really the most we
can hope to have and this is what we
achieve in a public election the
challenge now is to
achieve the same thing with a secret
ballot election and that's where the
cryptography comes in and there are turn
out to be multiple ways of achieving
these goals some very creative ways have
come up for both parts for the checking
that votes have been recorded properly
and for the tallying but the tallying
tends to be highly cryptographic either
by using homomorphic tallying methods
which compute on encrypted data and
transform these individual encrypted
votes into encrypted tallies or there's
another approach that's commonly used
called a mixed net which is basically a
cryptographic shuffle of the ballots
which has some benefits it also has some
privacy concerns so there are trade-offs
but it's good to have both techniques
available well and in fact we're gonna
have trade-offs no matter what I mean
it's just a matter of what is the sweet
spot for what we're willing to reveal
versus what we want to keep private yes
and that manifests itself very
distinctly in the election context
because you would think that it would be
a good thing to have all the ballots be
public in the end but if the ballots are
public then it allows voters to sell
their votes once again by various little
tricks for instance if I work for a
small company say with a couple hundred
employees and the owner of the company
is running for mayor
the owner can say I want everybody in
the company to vote for me as mayor and
there's some minor office down at the
bottom of the ballot you know dog
catcher type of office writing your own
name there and I will now look at all
the public ballots that have been
published and make sure that for each of
you there is a ballot if that form and
if I don't see a ballot with your name
for dog catcher and my name for mayor
don't bother coming to work tomorrow
interesting and that is a sort of an
obvious way of revealing things but
there are less obvious ways that can be
used that are collectively called
pattern voting where
a different pattern is assigned to each
voter of the low-level rightists and
that pattern had better appear so Town
Council has ten different seats then
there are ten factorial ways of ordering
the names and the local controlling
entities usually said yes could just go
around and assign a different
permutation to each voter and say if
this permutation doesn't appear on a
ballot then whatever consequences might
occur suddenly Josh don't feel so good
exactly you know there's another side of
it too in the 21st century where if your
vote was made public it wouldn't just be
the vote buying thing it would be the
Twitter mobbing afterwards if somebody
decided they didn't like how you voted
they can ruin your life after the fact
yeah well I mean if these are all
ruining your life after the fact kind of
things sure that there could be vote
shaming of various vote shaming what a
fascinating word we've invented a new
term I love it
[Music]
okay so cryptography in general being a
way to get closer to that sweet spot
what's the math and the theory behind
this our listeners are pretty technical
and I've seen some of your slides on
this I didn't understand any of the
slides but I saw them that's because you
didn't hear me talking about don't
explain them they're easy it's busy
so homomorphic encryption has existed
for over 30 years when I was an
undergraduate I took a cryptography
class from Ron Rivest at MIT and Ron is
great and Ron does in many of his
classes and I do this very often when I
teach whenever I can is have students do
projects at the end of the semester or a
quarter or whatever it is and in this
case this was in the spring of 1981
there just been an election in 1980 it
was a three-way election and I was sort
of naively thinking maybe if we could
computerized this somehow we could have
ways that would allow people to express
their preferences in some ways you know
I didn't know at the time that it
doesn't really work very well
no there's arrows theorem and related
theorems that say that there's nothing
good that we can do with preference
lists but I was thinking about this and
I decided I would do my project on
Elections and ron handed me a paper that
he'd written with a few colleagues
Adelman and ER to Zoe's called privacy
homomorphisms which talked about how you
can manipulate data that had been not
encrypted but protected in some way and
mathematically yes and I had been a math
major jumped on the word homomorphism I
knew what that meant
you know it meant that you can apply an
operation that preserves the structure
of something so I thought yes yeah maybe
I can do that in this context and I did
a few
sort of week things along that line for
my project none of it really worked but
these were interesting ideas years later
when I found myself in a doctoral
program and looking at thesis topics I
had much better tools available to me I
knew a lot more and the field had grown
and I realized that I could actually do
something that went much further to
solving that problem and started using
homomorphic encryption as a way of
enabling an election that really could
be verified elections really come down
to doing addition it's just ones and
zeroes who you voted for
and the tallies are just adding them up
and there's really not much more than
that so the trick is basically if we
have an additively homomorphic function
then we can take encrypted votes and
apply this additive homomorphism and we
get an encryption of the tally sure and
that's pretty much all there is to it
there's a whole thesis than that well
there's a little bit more than thesis
but that was the core idea that's
awesome and it turns out could be done
very efficiently so I invented a little
additive homomorphic encryption system
of my own the general form of RSA at
least typically used a large exponent
RSA in its practical usage today
typically uses a small exponent and my
encryption system used to small
exponentiations which is a lot more
efficient than one large one sure so it
was an efficient way of doing things
people have been interested in home
Orphic encryption for years thing well
there are additive homework encryption
systems there are multiplicative
homomorphic encryption systems I wonder
if we could do something that would do
both at the same time and it turns out
that if you can do addition and
multiplication together then you can do
everything you can do any computation
because you can break computations down
into addition and multiplication it's
really the equivalent of ands and ORS
but people thought for many many years
it would be nice but there are good
reasons to think that this just can't be
done and then about 10 years ago it
turned out it could be done it was Craig
Gentry that found a way to do this that
was wildly inefficient it slowed things
down by I think about twenty five orders
of magnitude about ten to twenty fifth
slower than doing the computation circus
yes that's of course ridiculous you
can't do the you know the simplest
computation with that and there's been a
lot of research since then on bringing
that down and now it's down to about ten
orders of magnitude for general
computation which is still very painful
but there are cases where it's far more
efficient and this is a tool that allows
for computation on data in encrypted
form so once we have that then we really
enable very powerful cloud data services
and we can do some of that today we
can't do all of it because the general
computation is still nowhere close to
efficient enough the reason I want to
distinguish it is I want to make clear
that even though we're using home
morphic encryption for elections we're
using what now come to be called simple
homomorphic encryption which is very
efficient we've heard the pronouncements
people aren't going to put public
elections on the internet until it is
end-to-end verifiable and we can't do
that yet so we're not doing this yet
right well I would say a little bit more
that's what I want you to do okay the
speculative technology now where is it
being used is it being used no it is not
speculative yes it is being used so
end-to-end verifiable election systems
do exist and have been fielded in a
variety of contexts they tend to be in
small localized contexts there was an
end-to-end verifiable system used in
Takoma Park Maryland for a couple of
public elections give you a few hundred
voters but they used a very nice and an
verifiable system they are called scan
Tegrity when the voters liked it very
much but it was a lot of work and after
doing elections in I believe
was 2009 and 2011 Tacoma Park was very
happy to continue it but the researchers
who had put a lot of time and effort
into if we're saying at that point find
a way to do it yourself please and of
course there was nobody to pick it up so
it hasn't been done so much sense okay
there's an internet-based and an
verifiable system called Helios that's
used in a variety of places it's used
commonly by professional societies like
the ACM uses this the IAC R it's the
International Association for
Cryptologic research and many
professional courses they do well
actually it was very hard to bring this
in because cryptographers are very
suspicious people that was funny right
there it was quite a challenge to move
the community to this what the community
had been doing was mailing out paper
ballots and double envelopes and such
and many people thought we should
continue doing that even though it cost
tens of thousands don't eat your own dog
food well we weren't but eventually the
economics together with the import of
the election moved us to you know we can
really do this many of our offices
there's only one candidate there aren't
a lot of people spending a lot of money
trying to steal this election it's okay
I would not recommend this for public
elections not today
end-to-end verifiability is a very
valuable tool and it mitigates a lot of
the concerns of Internet voting I was a
part of a us vote foundation study that
was published three years ago that
looked at using end-to-end verifiability
for internet voting and some of the
conclusions were that it's absolutely
unconscionable to do internet voting
without and and verifiability it
mitigates many of the problems in a way
that nothing else can and without it
it's just so vulnerable
you shouldn't even touch it however
there are still problems even with and
and verifiability
that have not been adequately mitigate
and therefore we should not be doing
that today even with and verifiability
what the report recommends is we should
be using antenna verifiability
in in-person elections and poll sites in
traditional ways first getting more
experience with it before we contemplate
the next step of moving it into the
internet realm we should definitely be
doing things carefully any time we try
something new it's good to put it after
the public to have dry runs and trials
there was an Internet voting system that
was built for Washington DC a few years
ago and it was actually built very well
although it was intent and verifiable
but it was open source it did many of
the right things the code was actually
quite good and they did the right thing
of putting it out for a public challenge
in a mock election before it was
actually used and a professor at the
University of Michigan Alex Halderman
got a few students to look at this
during the trial and they eviscerated
the system they they were watching the
internal cameras in the voting center
watching the workers look at what was
going on they were able to compromise
all of the votes change all the votes to
anything they wanted they changed the
actual voting mechanism and put the
University of Michigan fight song at the
end of the voting process the first that
the election officials in DC got wind of
what was going on was when they started
getting complaints from voters saying I
really like this internet voting process
but that music at the end is kind of
annoying and that's when they discovered
that this trial had been hacked and they
did cancel the project I always ask my
guests on this podcast what keeps you up
at night I want this
and to end verifiability to be there
it's not but what not we to be thinking
as we now know these things I think that
were made clearer maybe we had our head
in the sand a little bit
there's a lot that we can do name so I
was an author of a report that was just
released in September it was released by
the national academy of science
engineering and medicine called securing
the vote protecting American democracy
there's a lot of good stuff in the
report a few highlights I can give now
feel free to download it yourself I
think it's a very readable report but
some of the highlights include that of
course the 2016 election was infiltrated
but we saw no evidence of actual
tampering with votes themselves even
though we know now that's very possible
we didn't see any evidence of that
in fact I was on a phone call with a
election officials from all over the
country two days after the election and
the consensus was that as far as the
casting and counting of votes go this
was the cleanest election that people
had seen in a long time there were
certainly some incidents but there were
relatively small compared to what is
typically seen in an election so we know
there are vulnerabilities and they
really do need to be addressed so there
are a few steps that can be taken
certainly we can apply best practices
things that are not being done today to
secure registration lists the better
secure the actual voting equipment and
there are things that we can do in terms
of basic general security practices that
most industry does today the problem we
have is that it's an asymmetric battle
elections in the u.s. are conducted
mostly at the county level there are
over 4,000 counties in the US there are
over 8,000 separate election
jurisdictions in the US and the thought
that a small County somewhere maybe in
an important swing state could have
enough cyber security in place to
withstand an attack from state-level
attackers is just not realistic
even though we can't defend an election
from being tampered with we can
institute good auditing and one method
of good auditing is this and then
verifiability that allows you as a voter
to see whether your vote has been
changed we have other methods of
auditing and there are better methods of
administrative auditing that can be used
but and verifiability offers a public or
that allows voters themselves to become
part of the process and to check for
themselves and candidates to check for
themselves and interest groups or news
media or others to do the checks so
that's something that I very much hope
that we'll be moving towards so in
conclusion we need more research classic
last line of a dissertation I'm actually
reluctant to say that yes it's true but
and the reason I want to say but is that
end-to-end verifiability is ready to go
now and many people are putting it off
and saying well that sounds good
you should do more research on it and
wait and sure there are ways that we
could improve it better usability
studies would be helpful there's a lot
of opportunity for good usability
research there's some opportunities for
other areas but usability applies in
traditional elections as well and we're
not saying well we haven't done enough
usability studies so we can't have an
election right let's do that research
but that doesn't mean we should wait on
deploying and to in verifiability
and the best tools that we have now and
then also let's do some research on how
to make them better
Josh Bonello thank you for coming on the
podcast it's been delightful having you
as a guest oh thank you so much Gretchen
this has been really a lot of fun
to learn more about dr. Josh Bonello and
how cryptographers are working to secure
the vote visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]